[Music]
good morning everyone perhaps good
afternoon good evening wherever you're
joining us from it's really a pleasure
to be here i always enjoy spending time
with participants in the cfar machine
learning deep learning reinforcement
learning summer school
a little bit sad we can't do it in
person but really happy we have time
together today
i'll share with you some of the
um
work that we've been doing this is work
that's primarily done with some of my
students at mcgill university over the
last few years but i will say since then
it has really grown throughout the
community and i've had the pleasure of
working on this topic
of how do we set up a better set of
experiments for research and
reinforcement learning with people
across the planet who are really deeply
involved in
raising our standards in terms of the
quality of our experimental work and at
the end of the talk um hopefully i'll
get there i will even have some
suggestions and tips if any of you want
to get involved into this work there's
lots of ways that you can actually
participate towards this effort
getting started um
one of the main reasons i'm really
interested in making sure that we have
good experiments and we'll spend some
time sort of discussing today what are
the conditions for doing that is because
we are seeing the speed at which in
ai in general but reinforcement learning
more specifically the we're moving from
research to technology development to
deployed applications so really this
pipeline of innovation from really the
inception of an idea to having a product
working in the world
is getting shorter
over time
whereas in other fields like
that we've seen much much longer
development time and ai often it's the
case that the new algorithm comes up and
you know three months later it's
actually running in product
and so that means that we have really a
high responsibility in terms of making
sure that each of the step of the
development that we invest in is
actually done in a way that meets our
high standards of quality whether we're
building navigation systems for
autonomous vehicles whether we're
building chatbot agents to allow
interactions between human and machines
or whether we're
developing and deploying intelligent
robots to assist in surgery all of these
cases where people have used
reinforcement learning to improve the
behavior of the system
i assure you that no matter which of
these system i'm also including top left
an example of energy management smart
cities and grid systems where we also
have seen really promising rl
applications
in all of these cases we want to make
sure that when we run a reinforcement
learning agent in real time
that the performance is going to be
adequate based on our expectation that
it's not going to cause harm that we can
predict in advance what will be the
quality level of that system and so
that's really my deep motivation and
i'll share with you some applications
that we've worked in in our lab that
have motivated that more immediately in
our own work
but really thinking broadly about why do
i think it's important for us today
together to speak about conducting good
experiments this is the place where i'm
coming from
now i assume by now you know you have a
pretty good sense of how to build a
machine learning pipeline and this is a
very generic one but in many cases you
have this first phase of getting the
data and then there's another phase of
cleaning preparing manipulating the data
you may be training your model
you test your model after that and then
you improve and see what phase of the
system you need to go back to
this is a pretty
standard pipeline
in reality in each of these steps
there's a lot of decisions that have to
be made about how you are going to set
up this and this is what i'm calling
sort of the experimental pipeline how
you're going to set up each of these
steps
and if you're not careful about
really being precise about your design
choices and furthermore
documenting them in a transparent way
and can be quite difficult to verify the
quality of the work that you're doing
and so in a lot of the the work that i
do one of the key concepts that arises
in this discussion of better experiments
is the notion of reproducibility
and so reproducibility is really all
about having the ability to duplicate an
experiment to duplicate the results
the goal of reproducibility is really
that we want to achieve robustness and
so the
the idea is that if you run an
experiment
and if you're able to run you or someone
else is able to run that same experiment
again then you can have higher
confidence that the findings or the
conclusions of that experiments are
actually of a high quality
and this concept of reproducibility
actually permeates the world of science
it's not specific to ai or reinforcement
learning it's really very fundamental to
the scientific method
and one of the reasons we really
emphasize reproducibility is because it
gives us this high confidence in our
findings and so
really it will be the major theme of
what i talk about today when i talk
about better experiments what really
we're talking about is how do we build
experiments that are reproducible
experiments where we can have high
confidence in the conclusion that we're
drawing from the results that are
obtained
there's actually been a lot of
discussion in the last few years about
what is the state of reproducibility in
science in general so i'm sharing here a
quick snapshot of an article published
in the journal nature 2016
where 1500 or so researchers were asked
whether they thought there was a
reproducibility crisis within their
field of science
about 52 said yes there's a significant
crisis
38 said maybe a slight crisis and a few
of them didn't seem to be very concerned
about the situation
now beyond that the survey also asked
you know have you ever failed to
reproduce an experiment
and they asked both about whether you
failed to reproduce someone else's
experiment so in darker red or whether
you had failed to reproduce one of your
own experiments in
lighter red
and so what we see is that in many
fields chemistry biology
upwards of 60
of researchers have been in the
situation where they weren't able to re
reproduce someone else's experiment or
their own experiment
um the computer science isn't really
detailed there we'll dig more into it
today
but even in the physics in engineering
where you would think that perhaps it's
easier to reproduce experiments compared
to dealing with maybe bio biology or
chemistry still a very very high rate of
inability to reproduce certain
experiments um so that sort of sets the
stage for where we're at
in many ways when dealing with machine
learning there's a sense that we should
be able to do better you know we can
control much more of the data that we
use the algorithms that are running the
machines on which these algorithms are
running
and so in doing that we should be able
to meet a much higher standard of
reproducibility than perhaps some of
these fields where there's a lot more
extraneous variables that might affect
the result of the research
so for those of you who are interested
in digging in and seeing how we're doing
overall in machine learning i would
recommend this very nice paper published
just a few years ago
this researcher analyzed 250 so papers
from several years of machine learning
research and found that over that set of
papers around 63 percent of them were
deemed reproducible
he also dug in a little bit more and
analyzed what were the factors that
affected reproducibility so these are
factors that are going to come back in
our discussion today
one of them is the availability of
pseudo code even better in some cases
open source code
one of them is a clear specification of
what are the hyper parameters that were
considered in the experiments
another one is the readability of the
equations and the tables
in some cases if you're not able to
really understand what are the results
it's hard to make sure that you are
actually achieving them when you run the
reproducibility study
a fourth one was the compute needed
there's some work that is being produced
especially very recently that requires
enormous amounts of computation which is
perhaps not accessible
last one was the topic of the work so
that seemed to be a main driver there
are some sub-topics of machine learning
which are harder to reproduce than
others
the last point which i didn't highlight
here but also comes through if you look
at some of the the p-values which
indicate the significance of a
particular feature in reproducibility
is
the
conversation with the authors so the
ability to go back and forth with the
author to have more detail about their
experiment turned out to be a
determining factor in the ability to
reproduce experiments
so quite interesting to keep in mind
and i encourage each of you who's
interested to to go in and read the
paper and really learn what we can from
these many many years of experiments in
machine learning and the very nice
analysis that was done that really
starts giving you a sense of what
matters what are the types of procedures
and good habits you need to build into
your own experiments as you venture into
machine learning research
now i want to just give a little bit of
a landscape in terms of different terms
that are used across the community
i will say with a bit of a caveat that
these terms are not used always in the
same way across disciplines i'm basing
this by report that the nsf national
science foundation in the u.s has issued
recently about the notion of
reproducibility trying to crystallize
the definition of these terms so that's
the one i'm adopting today but i will
just warn you if you're digging into
this literature that there has been some
inconsistencies in how that's used in
the literature for the purposes of today
i'm going to assume that an experiment
or a result is reproducible
when we
are able to obtain the same conclusion
using the same code and analysis
and using the same data as the original
as the original experiment
and so that's really in a sense the
minimum standard everything else on this
board is harder than reproducibility but
yet that is where i'm starting because i
still think we have a lot of work to do
to achieve this
the notion of replicability is when you
actually apply the same code the same
analysis but on data that is different
so maybe you went ahead and collected
another data set and you see whether
that's actually replicable
the notion of robustness is when you
might use the same data but you might
have some changes in terms of the code
or the analysis so someone has maybe
gone from pseudocode to a new
implementation of the algorithm
and finally the lower right corner is
really what we're aiming for in the long
term right is to have generalizable
results so if you re-implement the
method redo the analysis using other
data that you still get the same result
that's really this notion of
generalization that we aim for that's
that's the long-term goal but for today
i will talk mostly about reproducibility
as being one step towards that
longer-term goal
most of my work of course is in the
field of reinforcement learning from
what i understand you already had a day
of amazing lectures on reinforcement
learning yesterday so i'm not going to
get back into the basics but just to
ground us this is really the setting in
which most of my work has been done
and that setting has had
really impressive success in games
that's where we've seen it shine and
it's made the headlines
but it's useful to remember that beyond
those games where reinforcement learning
has had some
very visible success there's a long list
of potential real world applications
where reinforcement learning could
really be a game changer in our ability
to develop some high quality technology
i mentioned a few of them in the opening
of the talk
but there's actually a much much longer
list that is under investigation
including some assistive robotic devices
including some personalized tutoring
system forest fire management and on and
on
and so in a sense i'm not so concerned
about reproducibility for building
systems that can play go or that can
play poker i'm really concerned about
having strong reproducibility
for these types of applications that are
going to go into everyday life of people
in some cases maybe playing a major role
in their health and their education in
their
environment let me take a pause there
before digging in if there's some
questions about some of the basic
concepts and then i'll
i'll launch into the next piece do we
have any questions liam
yeah we have a few so uh florian gables
asks how is
reproducibility affected by time i
expect older papers tend to be more
famous papers and thus are more likely
to be reproducible also in the last 20
years the ml field got away from more
competitive causing more bad actors
exactly
yeah i think there's different factors
we haven't done a timing analysis of it
there's some things that are
easier from the past you know
computation is rarely an obstacle we
have so much more computation now than
we did
10 years ago um
in many cases the the types of tasks
that were done that were attempted in
those earlier papers were simpler and
therefore by its nature really easier to
reproduce one thing that's harder is in
many cases we don't have code from the
early days whereas it's now become much
more common for people to open source
their code
we also often don't have the same
ability to contact the authors and so
some people have moved out of research
and so on and so forth and so it's
really not as easy to get into the
details so there's some of these factors
that that come into play
related question about
publishing code i guess it's a personal
asking for your personal opinion do you
think that publishing code of
implementation should be compulsory
uh for publishing research
i
i tend to be like not one that dwells
with absolutes so i'm not gonna go so
far as being compulsory i will say i
think it's absolutely a responsibility
of anyone who engages in science to be
transparent in doing that so for me
publishing code is absolutely a
first step towards this i will say even
for people working in industry if you're
engaging in research
then publishing your code should be
expected
on the side of data i think it's a lot
more nuanced how we think about that
there are many reasons why data needs to
be treated with appropriate
confidentiality privacy standards
whether it's healthcare data
identifiable data and so on so there i
think we need a much more nuanced
discussion okay great and uh point of
clarification maybe from the last slide
uh on the difference between
replicability and generalizability
yeah just going back quickly to this one
right in replicability and again i'm
really using the framework that's
proposed by nfc
in replicability we assume that the data
set is not necessarily the same but that
the code and the analysis is the same
whereas in generalizability you may
actually have slightly different methods
for the code for the analysis maybe
different storage system maybe different
optimizer that's used and so the results
are in a sense assumed to be you know
much more
robust and and generalizable to other
cases
[Music]
so the ideas really could be robust to
variance of both data and code and
analysis
um
okay i stop me when you feel like we've
done enough because there's lots you
know what like last one and then we'll
we'll keep it back okay
do you know if there are any suggestions
on how to write reproducible research
code
we'll get to some of that at the later
phase and then i will probably suggest
some um
some specific tools
i think in many cases one of the things
we can do to help us each is to have
tooling and best practices and
guidelines of how to do that so it's not
general so in the last part of my talk
i'll get into more specifics in terms of
tooling both for code and more generally
for experiments
okay great
let's uh let's tell the short part of
the story and we'll pause again for
questions maybe in 20 minutes or so and
also at the end
so i mentioned that i have a deep
interest in applications and this is
where this is motivated in many ways and
so um in
in some of the earlier work that we've
done we looked at developing a neural
stimulation device for epilepsy
so think of this as a small device
implanted in the chest cavity that has
electrodes running into the brain some
of these electrodes are in real time
reading the signal the eeg signal from
the brain from the patient and some of
the other electrodes are actually
develop
are actually
giving a electrical signal in the form
of periodic stimulation
to essentially disrupt the neural signal
in the brain and the
principle being that if you disrupt the
signal
the brain doesn't move into the state of
hypersynchronization so epilepsy happens
when all the neurons suddenly decide to
fire together but by adding external
signal you're disrupting that
synchronization ability and that means
that you can prevent epileptic seizure
in patients so these devices are in use
in patients they stimulate different
areas
of the brain depending on the patient
most of them are operating on an open
loop control system so they're just
stimulating at a particular frequency
without considering what is the
real-time activity so there's
essentially no sensing electrode
and so in our work we really worked at
using reinforcement learning to improve
the stimulation strategy in a way that
we can reduce the frequency of seizures
the duration and also reduce the amount
of stimulation that's provided compared
to periodic strategy
and so in this case you know the signal
we're reading is a live eeg signal and
in this case we're really trying to
deliver the stimulation so here you see
a case of periodic stimulation where
every second the system was essentially
poked electrically
there was already evidence that this
stimulation at a periodic pattern was
effective in disturbing the patterns of
hypersynchronization so preventing
seizures but there hadn't been any work
on using adaptive learning to improve
the strategy in terms of stimulation so
that was the essence of our project and
i can you know at some point later on
share much more of the details of this
experiment but it sort of just set the
stage with the kind of safety critical
application that i'm dealing with
all of our work was done in an animal
model of epilepsy and so this is a slice
of the brain
of a rat that is put in a particular
solution
where we can plant the electrodes and
observe the seizures in this case the
seizures are induced by a particular
chemical that's put in the solution
rather than a naturally epileptic animal
and in that system we literally come in
with a laptop and plug in you know our
stimulation electrode and our sensing
electrode as input and output of that
laptop and we run a closed-loop
reinforcement learning system
um and so we can imagine you know
whatever results we get in this
particular animal model we want to make
sure that they're actually transferable
to other live animal or humans cases and
so this standard of reproducibility is
really motivated by making sure that the
experiments i conduct in the simpler
setting are really reliable enough to
know whether we should move
to the other settings
and again you know if you want to go and
read about some of the the work we've
done that we've published a number of
papers on this topic that the conclusion
of it was that after several months of
investigation this was really a
three-year study
we were able to show that we could have
as good of a reduction of seizures
compared to some of the periodic
strategies with much fewer
many fewer um actual stimulation actions
so that was quite positive but if you
look at the fine print at the bottom
right we spent about six months building
up the training data we spent about six
months training the algorithm
but then just the validation phase so
running the experiments to confirm that
the rl train strategy was doing better
than the baseline took two years so
imagine you're running an experiment you
essentially get one experiment it's
going to take two years and at the end
you will know whether your algorithm
works or not
so
thinking back to that pipeline i had the
experimental pipeline on slide two or
three you know that phase of going back
and improving um you only get to do it
after essentially three years in this
case
and so the stakes are very very high
that whatever you've done in the initial
phase is actually of high quality enough
and then you sort of run your experiment
but cross your fingers that it's gonna
work
um in our case fortunately you know we
did have uh
promising enough results to to continue
to publish um
but that wasn't necessarily gonna be a
second try and it's quite different than
a lot of the machine learning
experiments that are being done today
you know and i we don't do all of our
work in this mode i have lots of other
work where you know you launch an
experiment you go grab a copy 40 minutes
later you have your results um but i
just want to bring to your mind sort of
the different cases depending on what
the type of application you're doing and
you're trying to
really solve it may be very different
setting and and there may be cases where
it's really important that you up your
game in terms of the quality of your
experiments otherwise you're essentially
losing three years worth of work as well
as the ability to have a positive health
impact on people
and so this is one of the cases that's
motivated me
when you take on one of these
applications of course as you can
imagine you can't afford to just try out
all the algorithms out there and and
really figure out through trial and
error what works and what doesn't work
we didn't have a simulator for this
particular case we had offline batch
data to train from we weren't even able
to train online
and so there's a lot of constraints that
are imposed by the setting in which you
work
and so we looked at the literature the
set of you know papers that were
available to try to pick the method that
we thought was the was the most
promising one and as you can see there's
a huge number of papers published every
year on rl
and if each of these paper doesn't adopt
a really good methodology no matter how
good i am in setting up my own work if
each of these papers on which i'm basing
my work doesn't use as good of a
methodology i'm a little bit stuck
because i have to redo all of their
experiments before even knowing how to
set up my own experiment
and so in this case um
you know i'm going to focus on a
particular study we did trying to
compare some of these algorithms in the
literature this is a little bit separate
from the epilepsy case we did do this in
simulation but we were really trying to
dig into this question a little bit
similar to the article from edward
earlier but in a much more restrictive
setting of policy search methods for rl
what was the quality of reproducibility
of these methods and so we picked four
algorithms
listed here and the reason we picked
them frankly is because they were used
often as baseline across the literature
so over and over again we come with
people presenting new methods for rl but
they were comparing their new methods to
one or a few of these existing papers so
they'd become really a reference set for
the field
and we wanted to know are they are they
a good reference set if if your
baselines aren't the right one whatever
you compare to it it's going to be hard
to draw the right conclusions
and we had a suspicion that perhaps the
way people were using these algorithms
wasn't the right way in terms of
establishing reproducible results
so let me tell you a little bit what
happened when we did this
we we we consider the four algorithms
and this is not in any way a critique
necessarily of these four algorithms
it's really trying to dig into this
question of how to run good experiments
um and so i'm not necessarily going to
tell you which is better or not so don't
base your own
analysis on this but we consider this
cheetah domain it's a classic of the
majok literature you essentially have a
simplified animated agent learning to
run so what you're seeing on this short
video is what happens when you're
successful in training your half cheetah
in learning how to run
we applied the four algorithms as you
can see you know algorithm red turned
out to be better than the other three
we then move to other cases there's a
hopper and there's a swimmer and they're
all using the same kind of physics and
um and observation and when we moved to
these other ones we found that in hopper
the blue algorithm which had been worse
for cheetah was actually the best when
we moved to swimmer blue was doing
really well again but in that case was
really unstable and you see that by the
very very large arabians that are shown
whereas red was essentially unable to
learn
so this is a little bit troubling
because those three environments are
actually operating on very similar
dynamics and so anything i want to
conclude from this and take to doing a
project such as my epilepsy you know
stimulation system
it's very hard to do when even comparing
a cost across three very very similar
environments you get very different
results
so we started digging in a little bit to
understand what was behind this really
high variance between the results um we
thought maybe we are not getting the
right code so you know one of the
reasons we picked these is also because
there was a lot of open source
implementation we had grabbed one that
was
perhaps the best known one we went
digging around and found lots of other
repos
trying to implement the same algorithm
and what we found is if you take three
different implementation of trpo which
should be the same algorithm
you get three results of this type
and so if you go back to my you know my
my topology of robustness replicability
reproducibility and so on you see what
happens in this case where same data
different code based implementation
and you see quickly that the results are
changing
that's a little bit surprising but it's
not unique to trpo we ran the same thing
with ddpg and had similarly very
different results
we were not going to be stopped there
you know a big part of research is just
trying to understand and just like
following the piece of the story that
you don't understand and so you know in
many ways that's one of the good
qualities of a
researcher
um so we started digging into different
reasons that might explain the variation
one of them that just jumped out is the
network structure so depending how you
were setting up the neural network that
was representing your policy you had
very different results
we changed the number of layers the
number of nodes per layer as you can see
lots of different results
we change the activation function that
also caused quite a few different
results
we started digging into all of these
factors of variation and found out many
ways they vary jointly
so we looked at the
reward scales in some cases people
normalize the reward itself the reward
function but then in other cases people
apply normalization at each layer of the
neural network so there's definitely an
interaction between these two factors
really at the end of the day there was
such a large number of these
experimental factors to consider
that that explained most of the
variation we were seeing between these
algorithms and these methods
so some of this is reassuring because we
we understand it's not black magic we
understand what are the pieces that are
affecting this at the same time there's
a large number of these
pieces
and we also observed a bias in the way
that the researchers were sending their
experiment in that the amount of work
that went into
finding the optimal configuration of
these parameters for one's own method
wasn't really the same investment that
one was putting into finding the best
hyper parameter for the baseline
algorithm so i assume you know many of
you have read a lot of research papers
in which you see you know you're
proposing a new method you're comparing
to a bunch of baseline methods so really
the tricky question is are you going to
be as motivated and spend as much time
computation
finding the right setting
for the method that you're proposing as
you are for the method that you are
comparing to so previous methods in the
literature and
you know human behavior and psychology
being what it is you know there's a
there's a strong suspicion that people
often don't do this in a systematic way
and while we might think that setting up
a fair comparison between method a
method b is easy same amount of data
same amount of computation we're done
in practice this is not what is
happening in a very large number of
studies
let me show you one example that was
particularly revealing in this case
um
my students ran two different methods
the blue and the orange they came back
and said okay we
we're very tight in controlling all the
factors of variation we ran five
iterations of each we're averaging the
results reporting the standard error
and we get this um difference which
suggests that the orange method is
better than the blue method so you know
this was after several weeks of this
work on reproducibility we said okay
um interesting so so what are the two
methods you're comparing here
and it turns out
those two are exactly the same method
same code in both cases same budget same
data for finding the hyper parameter
configuration
the only thing that was different is the
set of seeds that were used to run each
of these experiments the seeds come in
because there's some randomization in
some of the initial conditions
of the learner
and so this is really troubling because
in a sense the same method it seems like
there's an advantage to one when in fact
it's not supported so there was a little
bit of luck in how the seed split into
those cases um but it's still very very
concerning in terms of our ability to
draw robust conclusion from such an
experiment
and so it's good to step back and think
like how are we actually measuring
performance of these policies in many
cases what we show is the dark line is
the average over the test trial
and then the colored bar around it is
really the confidence interval
many cases we look at a 95 confidence
interval the main factor that we get to
pick is how many experiments do we run
and so in the example before we had run
five experiments of each
i asked my student why did you pick five
experiment is that the right numbers
should we pick more
i said well we looked in the literature
and five seems to be like the rough
number of experiments that people are
running if nothing else seems to be the
mode
of the the experiments at the time this
was a few years ago
and so if you look at this you know
there's a funny thing that's happening
this is the number of trials three to
nine means some experiments some
results were done on three experiments
other results were done on nine
experiments and there's a funny thing
that happened that some of the papers
were only reporting the top two or the
top three results so they may be running
a hundred experiments but they were only
going to report the top two top three
top five results
and that kind of strategy was sort of
creeping into the community and if you
go today and look at papers from this
era and sometimes maybe even papers if
today in reinforcement learning be very
very careful about how they set up this
particular part of the experiment
let me show you what happens when you
only look at the top three results so
this is the case where i ran 10
different experiments and let's say i
have a particular baseline i want to
beat
so if i run 10 experiment and i look at
the results this doesn't seem very
convincing i didn't draw the the average
in the confidence interval but that
doesn't seem very convincing that you
know we have um
substantial evidence that we can beat
the baseline
if i just keep my three best experiments
this is what it looks like
so suddenly i have a very strong
positive bias
and also the variance appears much
smaller
so if the baseline computed properly
the mean and the confidence interval
over several examples but someone comes
along and they decide to just show the
top three results
in doing so they will have a very strong
positive bias and a smaller variance and
thus their method will start to seem
advantageous
and so unfortunately there's many
um papers in the literature that that
have done this over the years what's
even more damaging is when as a set of
papers starts to do this even people who
are very motivated in terms of having
good reproducibility which says you use
the same analysis
we'll use this particular analysis
method because it's the same one as
previous literature
and we really get into a culture of poor
experimentation um
even though we um we we should not be
doing this
and so
the the take home from this i think is
twofold one of them is in reinforcement
learning there are many many sources of
experimental variation it's good to be
aware of all of them
and to be
thorough in deciding how you're going
to control for them do it in a way that
is fair for your methods the second one
is to be really thorough in how you
report your results
and 18 that were published across top
conferences
and we found that even though all the
papers
had experiments used neural networks um
and described the hyperparameters for
the new algorithms that they were
proposing um in many ways on other
addings that we would strongly recommend
that they do
so you know one of them is making sure
that you thoroughly document all the
hyper parameters for the baseline
methods
including a link to the code so that
people can actually reproduce your
methods
specifying how you went about choosing
the hyper parameters for all the methods
or algorithms in the paper
running an evaluation on a proper hold
out test set
and finally properly running
significance testing
to support the conclusion of your
analysis so these are all ingredients
that i think are very important when
reporting experiments in reinforcement
learning also this applies to many other
fields of machine learning to keep in
mind
where i think in many cases the
community has fallen short as we see by
this really brief analysis
let me pause here before i jump into a
few you know solutions tools and so on
let's take a couple questions and then
i'll i'll do the last bit of attack that
is a little bit more practical this is
really raising the alarm but i will
provide you with some some practical
suggestions to avoid some of these
pitfalls liam
yeah so there are several questions
they're like what can we do so i will
skip those for now
don't cover them in the next 10 minutes
okay so
uh
in my experience i've noticed a general
lack of sensitivity about the different
test environments and the different
inherent difficulties that some
environments have compared to others
very often articles that propose
experiments in real environments were
compared to others that analyzed the
effectiveness of the algorithm in small
discrete and often non-dynamic
environments how do you think we can
increase the attention of some
researchers to the large amount of work
prior to adapting an algorithm from a
choice problem to a real problem
it's a it's really a challenge and we've
seen this over and over again i will say
that there's a relatively small number
of people who are really willing to get
their hands dirty and work with real
world data i
i hope that many many more people would
be willing to do that um and i hope the
the upcoming generation of researchers
will will really engage in this
you know for me one of the there's two
really ingredients here one of them is
transparency to be really thorough and
transparent in reporting the steps of
your research and the trade-offs and the
limitations of anything you've done
and secondly it's really entering always
the work from a mindset of understanding
of inquisition not trying to win any
medals this is not the olympics this is
not how research is best done but really
the spirit of inquiry and of growing our
knowledge together and those two
ingredients i think if you keep that
really top of mind are are the guiding
lights for doing this kind of work
great uh question from matthew mcfarland
that i think you partially answered in
the last slides of your talk but given
the large variability and results for
different implementations of the same
baseline does this mean we have to be
skeptical of all research we read how
can we identify the papers that present
results we can rely on
yeah you should always be skeptical um
at the same time you know there's only
so much energy you can put on
reinvestigation i i do think as a
community of research we don't spend
enough time being skeptical reproducing
work investing in testing the robustness
of our knowledge
versus always you know there's a there's
a
there's a real i'm not sure how to call
it but like a fetishizing of novelty
that i think is damaging to the quality
of the research process and so i think
we need to invest more in that
um and each of us needs to carry a part
of that and i'll give some tips on that
coming up in a minute last question
maybe and then we'll conclude and take
some of the others at the end okay great
so this is a question from pooja siren
in social science research
reproducibility is not possible because
data varies very dramatically over time
how can generalization be taken into
account in these settings
yeah
and as much as you know i i i
i call for better behavior in in
machine learning research i think in
some of the other fields this is much
much harder to do and so reproducibility
is strictly defined here isn't feasible
as was mentioned you really but
generalizability is always in
right
you always have the ability to describe
your approach and results in another lab
to carry that study
and so in some cases you know in in
clinical science it's really common to
do multicentricular protocol across
several hospitals because we know that
whichever hospital ran the study is a
major factor in the results when you do
the analysis of you know what are the
causal factors that explain the results
the location is one so then we set up a
multi-center study so i think there's
some of this practices that can be
carried to other fields to help reduce
that variance
great let me jump in with a few
recommendations of where we're moving as
a field and as a community and i'll take
a few last questions at the end
um
you know one thing i want to recognize
is machine learning systems are complex
there are several aspects to to consider
when building our experiments whether
it's the the code the implementation the
machines we're running on the sys the
data that also the social systems in
which we're embedding our work
um and so we have to be careful of
considering that
on the um perhaps on the more optimistic
side you know
we we have dealt with many many other
complex system and i'm i'm pointing out
two of them here because they've been an
inspiration to some of the solutions
we've drawn one of them is um
you know flying and flying an airplane
was not always as safe as it is today
put yourself back a hundred years and
and really there was a lot more
uncertainty about the outcome of any of
any plane ride yet over time the
industry has really raised its standards
in terms of ensuring safety and it's
remarkably more safe today
than it was a hundred years ago and
another case is really what we're seeing
in in surgery right
very
very much the same thing surgery had
been performed for centuries but really
the amount of care that goes into
ensuring as safe procedures
has really improved in the last few
decades and and they're both fields
where they've used very simple tools to
raise that you know there's been of
course amazing innovation at the
technology level but one of the simplest
tool that they have used repeatedly is
the use of a
checklist both in the cockpit and in the
surgery room a very prescriptive
checklist that the people the actors go
through while engaging in their activity
and so um in recent years we've proposed
similarly a machine learning
reproducibility checklist it's available
it's a set of different questions that
you can run through for your own work
that gives you higher certainty that you
sort of checked all the possible sources
of variation
and with a goal to having much more
reproducible work so there's five
sections in the checklist the first one
is about all the models and the
algorithms you present the checklist is
meant to be used when you write a paper
for a scientific conference or journal
but it can actually be adopted much
earlier on in the process of conducting
a research project
so for the models and the algorithms you
want to clearly describe what you're
doing the assumptions the analysis of
complexity for the theoretical claim you
want to make sure you're stating it
clearly have a complete proof for the
data set there are several factors to
consider and it's useful to be very
transparent about each of them be able
to describe them
for all the code that you want to share
again a relatively short list of
ingredients that if you can include the
dependencies training code evaluation
code pre-trained
models reading
file it's nothing really complicated but
you would be
shocked at how many papers published
today don't meet this basic standard and
for all the reported experimental
results we also have a number of items
that we recommend including and checking
again based on some of the analysis we
did of what were the missing pieces in
papers in the current literature and for
both you know some of the sections in
particular the code session we did a lot
of analysis on
github repositories to see what was the
correlation between whether people had
included these really simple components
or not and how useful was the code that
we're doing and we ran an interesting
analysis looking at um of the five items
that i listed or reproduced billy
checklist if you had one two three four
five of them how that was correlated
with the number of github stars that the
um repo would get and we see that you
know packets that have all five ticks
are
much more likely to have a large number
of
github stars so it seems relatively
simple in some ways and yet to be really
disciplined and diligent about this is
both going to have an impact in terms of
people's appreciation of your work and
also the scientific quality of your work
so this is a set of really practical
things that you can do i will give you
access to the slides so you'll be able
to dig into all of the links i do try to
include on most of my slides the
relevant link to to get more information
about the particular topic
beyond the this we also ran a
reproducibility challenge for the last
few years so we've invited people to
take a paper that was published at one
of these recent conferences
the challenge runs twice a year all you
have to do is sort of pick a paper
and set up to reproduce at least part of
the results of this paper and then write
a report about your reproducibility
and once we have enough submissions of
reports we actually review them peer
review the reproducibility reports we
select the best one and annually publish
an issue in the journal resigns with the
best reproducibility report so you can
go
and see the issues of the journal from
the last two years are out already and
we're going to be preparing a new
iteration for 2020. so this is another
place you can get involved even if
you're not at the stage of research to
produce your own innovative research
um you can certainly be a citizen
scientist and
participate by picking a work that has
been done and reproducing this you know
in many ways and lots of other sciences
we spend a lot of time learning the
techniques before carrying our own
experiments
and in machine learning i think this is
a great way to to learn the techniques
to develop your own
expertise in running some solid
experiments
and so if we look at what's new since
maybe 2018 when we started talking about
reproducibility in machine learning at
the time i sort of gave a keynote talk
at nurbs trying to call to
bring to the attention of the community
that we should be doing better in that
respect many things have happened we
have code submission policies at most
conferences
there's now a code tab that's
integrated in archive so when you look
at a paper in archive you can also
access the code and more recently the
data set there's a lot of tooling that
allows you to sort of create a tight
repo of your work i'm suggesting a few
of them here but there are more
there's the reproducibility checklist i
mentioned the reproducibility challenge
the issue of the journal resigns so all
elements that have been put in in a
sense we didn't invent any new science
to do this we just made it
common in the culture and in the
practice of our community to have higher
standards of reproducibility which we're
hoping will help us as a community have
more um effect and more impact with our
research
i'm going to conclude so i have time for
a few more questions before we have to
close the session
i think my main message is really to
keep uh top of mind focused on the fact
that science research is a collective
activity collective institution and
together we aim to understand and
explain
that's really the goal of what we're
doing in good practices in terms of
reproducibility reusability robustness
are important to contribute to this
i will close here a quick
acknowledgement to the many many
collaborators who participate in the
work i described today who have been um
really inspiring me to keep on doing
this work and some of them were
participants in the summer school a few
years ago
um and now autonomous researchers so
thank you to all of them
and i will take some questions
fantastic uh talk to all really
wonderful okay so
uh first question from martin
feriyank can you share with us a project
example which could act as a gold
standard to what we should consider a
reproducible or generalizable project
i'd have to dig in to come up with with
one of them i think one place to start
is actually in the in the journal
re-science where we've done the
reproduce billy issues and i'll be sure
to add the link on the slide where you
can access that easily there's a number
of reproducibility reports there and
you'll get a really nuanced discussion
of which were you know good or bad these
are all based on recently published
nerfs papers so it will give you some
concrete examples that have been vetted
peer-reviewed both the original paper
and the reproducibility report
okay great uh
could you please provide some examples
papers etc of current applications of rl
in terms of simulating the environment
after multiple agents take actions so
it's a little bit of a different
simulating the environment after
multiple agents take actions
yeah i'd have to i have to think a
little bit about that one maybe someone
wants to to follow up with me an email
on that or i think we're going to do
some q a in writing so maybe move that
to the writing section and i'll
i'll try to i'll try to dig up some some
examples i will say i've seen some
interesting cases in autonomous driving
where there's multi-agents that are all
carrying actions that depend on each
other i've also seen some interesting um
cases in games we had a paper a few
years ago on playing the game of
diplomacy with multiple agents um so
those are a couple i think fun
applications of this
cool
a question from audrey and
a cause of the
reproducibility crisis is the selection
bias in publishing where insignificant
results were rarely published which
incentivizes researchers to pick their
best results do you think the selection
bias in publishing also exists in
reproducibility venues
and could impact which papers are tested
what have you found successful in
motivating
researchers to reproduce research given
the risk that results may not be
reproducible
yeah that is definitely a strong factor
um
i think on reproducibility
results were a little bit more neutral
because we're we don't have as much of a
strong party of whether it's going to be
reproducible or not we're really
engaging fundamentally with the question
so i think it's a little bit less of an
issue there's definitely a bias we see
for example in the reproducibility
challenge we let people pick what paper
they want to reproduce there's
definitely a selection bias there of
what papers people are picking versus
not um and and we can't
nearly cover the set of them all i think
you know a conference like nurep says
upwards of a thousand papers and through
the reproduced billy challenge we tackle
maybe a couple hundred of them
so we're not close to coverage um one of
the things we've done is really
encourage
this challenge to be taken on as a
project in machine learning graduate
courses i think it makes a great final
project for anyone out there if all you
know graduate level machine learning
courses would take this on as their
um final course project would really
make a dent
in terms of that and really reduce that
selection bias which is a problematic
right now
great
uh how do you think we can encourage
researchers or organizations to enforce
better standards in a systematic way i.e
not hope the authors are well
intentioned uh can we enforce it uh
more in hindsight yeah for the last um
three years now nurex has adopted the
version of the checklist and it's
evolved a little bit through the years
but the checklist is used at these major
conferences like nerfs icml as part of
the submission process so the authors
actually have to fill it out and then
it's actually visible to the reviewers
um and so there's an accountability
mechanism there that gets built in this
year it was particularly clever they
built it into the latex style file that
the authors had to use so
it's really you know changing the
behavior through the the structure and
the tooling that's provided i think
that's one of the most effective things
we can do
to change this
um
i i like this question so very often
reviewers suspect of cherry picking up
rl environments because only a few are
presented while for small research
centers with limited resources those are
the only ones that could be tested while
big brands have plenty of machines and
can show lots of environments how can
the community be improved with common
criteria for everyone and i think
balancing the like
uh you know
the availability of compute with uh the
requirements for reproducibility
yeah
it's always a it's always a challenge
right like if you're picking the
environment you're essentially like
setting the bar and then you're showing
that you can you know jump over the bar
that's always a bit of a conflict of
interest um so and and at the same time
we have to acknowledge that the
resources are not always the same i i
want to point out a paper that was
written by um
by pablo castro and some of his
colleagues at google last year i think
it was really showing that there's still
a lot of value that can be obtained from
looking at smaller domains and
reinforcement learning it's a beautiful
paper
that i think is worth considering
especially for people who come
particularly from institutions where you
have
small access to data perhaps um not data
but compute um the way i always think
about it when i discuss with my students
and it happens to us also is always
like
yes it's fine to show results on a small
set of domains but are you the one who
are picking the domain or can we
actually lean on picking the domains
that someone else has picked so we
picked these five domains because these
were the five domains that were used in
this other paper so we're not picking
them ourselves we're
adopting them
because someone else suggested them so i
think there you reduce
the the cherry picking the other thing
is
to some degree selecting environments is
perfectly acceptable if you explain
what's your selection criteria and so i
i think we're at a phase of maturity of
our research that it's very rare that
you will publish an out or find discover
an algorithm that will be better on
every domain everywhere all the time
right so if you can focus on a smaller
class of domains but you explain why for
that class of domain this type of
algorithm is better
then i think that's perfectly reasonable
to do but you know the cherry picking is
not
great uh i also like this question so uh
it's hardest not to fool ourselves
what questions can we ask what tests can
we run to prevent human nature
especially for someone newer to research
it's very hard right uh richard feynman
has a beautiful quote of that which i
sometimes use in some of my talks about
you know you don't want to fool anyone
but you know the easiest person to fool
is yourself something to that effect
yeah to me that's that goes back to the
mindset it goes back to mindset of
inquiry and understanding and it goes
back to a strong commitment to
transparency and really finding that the
the
that is what drives us as researchers
otherwise you were sort of in the wrong
field one thing i didn't say is all the
work that we did on reproduce billy that
i shared today you know the comparison
of the results the not doing the top
three picks and so on all of that came
about in our lab because
not because we set out to do this at all
we were trying to produce the standard
paper where we had a new method that was
better than all these other methods
and yet it wasn't um and as we started
digging into why it wasn't this is where
we discovered all these really odd
things that other people were doing and
so at that point
we sort of pivoted and decided like this
was the more interesting story it was no
longer a story about showing our
algorithm was more interesting it was
much more the story about
what were some of the practices so
sometimes you know keeping an open mind
about what is the interesting part of
the research story that you are
apt to tell at a particular time point
in our
in our field is is something that you
should follow
it's harder publishing a paper with
negative results it's awesome but it's
harder um so you know really solicit all
the advice and the support you can get
from from experts and colleagues lean
into that collective wisdom to do that
kind of work it's really it's really
rewarding when you when you do it well
yeah it's a great example of following
your i guess scientific and intellectual
curiosity and now look at how much
impact this work has had which probably
i don't know how great the method that
you were thinking of publishing was but
certainly the impact of this work has
been huge
i think we should probably close it
there we're two minutes over uh thank
you so much joelle for the excellent
talk very thought-provoking and uh and
wonderful as always and so uh with that
i'll close this first session of the day
and we'll look forward to seeing
everybody later on in the further
lectures and then the career fair and
everything else thanks again thank you
thanks liam thanks everyone bye-bye
[Music]
you